is the door to iron man totally closed
because i don't believe it is
every day the reset button the space bar
gets pressed and it's like now what
30 years he has struggled with a
dangerous drug addiction that nearly
destroyed him and today he says he's
clean he's in love and so by the time
you're in prison that's not rock bottom
for you nope
it's easy to embrace hopelessness
when things seem insurmountable and yet
it's actually just a matter of time
until all the elements come together for
things to be all right i mean i believe
that you know most difficult situations
will resolve themselves if you are
persistent and if you don't give up
entirely and that's what i never did i
never gave up do you still get urges to
do drugs i have not
even an inkling of a desire
it's not that difficult to overcome
these seemingly ghastly problems what's
hard is to decide
that thing that you're wearing around
your neck yes being as you are obviously
known as being iron man are you
concerned with wearing a large thing in
the exact same spot life is funny
because i was doing this before i ever
got fitted for the rt so it was more of
art imitating oddball stuff i was doing
anyway
even more interesting because maybe you
were born to be iron man because iron
man obviously had that
loosely pre-arranged destiny
and what's incredible is how far afield
you can go from it and still find your
way back
this concept of things just sort of
falling into place i'm a big believer in
that too what is that though is that you
getting out of your own way isn't that
70 of it yeah yeah i'd say it's 70
maintenance of what can i do to do my
part to stay out of the way
and then the other part i always think
of it as like this little
super thin invisible thread
but you can feel the tug and you just
kind of you have to be really gentle you
have to pause when agitated and you have
to go for it when
you're gonna like it there's four walls
in here which one has the map behind it
you it's that one
and you knock down the wall and it's
there you know
yeah what is that though that's uh
synchronicity yeah uh
intuition
i don't know right that's the big i
don't know and i really feel it's so
funny
at this point in my life and being you
know kind of middle-aged and all that
well i know i'm gonna fly around the
world i'm gonna sell some soap and i
know i have a new project and i know
i've just retired my jersey on this
12-year journey i've been on and and how
do i want to start and it came up how
would you like to go yes that's exactly
what i'm going to do
i'm going to go
have the joe rogan experience and kick
off this year and this season and this
new chapter by doing what i love
i think part of the reason i'm still so
interested not just in life but also you
know getting to do what i do is i'm a
fan
i love movies i love creativity i love
music i love i love
culture
and the fact that i actually have a
place in it while i'm
observing it and digging it is like it's
it's
it's an honor
even though he has a whole lot of money
even though he's iron man
dude here's the deal
he's still nice my daughter is four
years old and she says daddy
don't you know iron man can't you hook
it up it's my birthday can he come to my
birthday can you make it happen daddy
and uh this is at his height
this is when it's everything is going
and i text him and i said listen man uh
my daughter
you know she loves iron man if you've
got time
you know what i'm saying you know if you
stop by and this is the day before her
birth it's saturday sunday is is the
birthday
he texts back he says
is 12 o'clock
noon good
is the door to iron man totally closed
because i don't believe it is oh you
guys can go through time now well let me
ask you the question
if i pick the jersey back up and put it
on wouldn't you feel a little bit like
uh
crap no oh i love you as iron man so i
would i would if you if they opened up
this time machine and you popped out i
just imagine the moment where everybody
goes [ __ ] crazy it would be amazing
it could be great i would love that but
i would also love you hanging it up
it's just i keep thinking
see clearly and it's difficult because i
i feel like we all just get buffeted by
feelings and
ego or fears or little you know
chips of resentments or intuitions that
are tied to something maybe higher but
you think is out of your reach or
whatever so i need to be kept
uh
right-sized because i can easily fall
into
self-seeking and depression and
self-pity and judgment and all that
stuff it's kind of a
it's a bit of a default but i spend
enough energy and i've had enough
help
over
enough years to actually just say oh
that's that's just
awful destructive behavior you're
entertaining in your head you know
if i'm noticing anything now it's that
we need
to shift and we need new challenges and
just like society and politics things
are moving and morphing and the
information age is making things so
everything's learning and growing from
everything so quickly and
improving or disproving but for me
it's just incredible
our culture never encourages taking a
break never encourages saying
don't chase that thing because you've
got it in your hands
so confidence you know there's been
times when i've felt i'm in possession
of it and then you want to let go a
little bit because
it's only ever the moment in life
guiding you the wind is so at your back
that you're like wow are you just are
you just you know jumping over the waves
and all that by yourself and you're like
you bet i am
but there's a physics to the moment and
the wind's at your back
and then the wind does what the [ __ ]
wind does and it changes and if you're
left there thinking what you know so i
think it's great to be in full
possession of what you would call
supreme confidence
and then see what happens if you don't
hold on to it so hard because
it's great
but it is a bit of an illusion because
like everything else it's always
changing always know what your action is
because then when you come in in the
morning confident or when you come in
the morning you can't hit your ass with
both hands you know what to do
just boil down what it is you're doing
whether there's a camera around or just
what am i doing today today i'm showing
up and i'm trying to be honest and and
also to listen and learn but really my
action today is i'm beginning a process
of promotion
you actually take comfort in the fact
that your eyesight is starting to
dwindle
you want to chase it but what i
appreciate is you know where you're at
by what you're able to retain if you
fight for it and the things that are
going no matter what you do sometimes
it's about
i don't need to try to
use something to hold on to everything i
want to pick the five or seven things
that i definitely want to hold on to and
i want to watch the rest of it go
in and out with the tides
smile
though your heart is aching
even though
it's breaking
when there aren't clouds
[Music]
you